[Music]
no it must be an anomaly tight again I
already have 20 times it's not an
anomaly this sample must contain a new
element a radioactive element it would
have to be hundreds no thousands of
times stronger than uranium we must
isolate it well then I suppose we're
going to need our own laboratory happy
do you remember the cooties paper on
darío activity working tirelessly side
by side without heat in the lab or
funding for the research it's romantic
wealth the Curie's spent four years on
that paper I've got three hours until
the patent office opens you should get
some rest you can't think probably
without sleep don't need sleep I need
more coffee
what does it do you remember our thought
experiments on gas theory at university
those weeks we spent holed up in my room
I don't never quite a lot of
experimentation yes not all of it to the
earth science what if going about it all
wrong
what if instead of studying gases we
studied a cup of coffee you really must
sweep up yacouba's van't hoff's no buy
the paper from 1901 particles in a
solution behaved like a gas when sugar
dissolves in coffee water surrounds
glucose and turns it from the sugar
crystal correct the more sugar I add the
thicker the coffee becomes if we can
calculate the osmotic pressure perhaps
we can deduce the precise number no one
to prove the existence of Marge's too
ambitious no it's pretty
you